donc tout a commencé en fait le 30 avril
2015 donc c'est tout frais et ça a
commencé j'étais allongé dans mon lit et
j'ai vraiment au petit matin vers 4
heures du matin j'ai vraiment senti des
secousses qui venait pas qu'ils
semblaient venir du ventre de la terre
j'ai appris plus tard que le volcan
allait bientôt entre en éruption et
vraiment des moments j'ai senti les
premières contractions qui me parcourt l
vente je pouvais pas rester allongée
j'ai déjà eu deux autres enfants et je
savais que si je quand on reste pas
allongé sur son lit
c'est que c'est vraiment le moment une
femme ne peut pas couché à coucher
allongée c'était mon repère donc là je
me suis dit là c'est une vraie
synchronicité s'il n'y a pas de doute
c'est le jour j il va naître aujourd'hui
il va arriver bientôt
gilles a attendu pendant neuf mois et
l'agérie commencé à réveiller toute
l'âme et la maisonnée j'ai réveillé mon
compagnon j'ai dit là il faut qu'on
arrange toute la maison je rajoute une
petite parenthèse j'ai fait le choix
d'accoucher à la maison effectivement
donc on a fini d'installer tout dans la
maison et là je me sentais prête je
crois que j'étais peut-être it cette
croyance populaire qui disait le
troisième enfant c'est comme une lettre
à la poste
alors je n'y croyais donc j'étais très
excité déjà de pouvoir tenir ce petit
être entre mes bras et voilà j'étais là
avec toutes mes projections tous mes
petits scénarios à me dire bon appli
devrait naître à peu près en fin de
matinée on va pouvoir célébrer tout ça
mais il se trouve qu'à midi j'étais
encore là en train de marcher dans la
maison de dix roquettes génial qu'est ce
qui se passe
j'ai des contractions c'est intense très
régulier et d'un coup ça s'arrête c'est
le calme plat
ok j'ai commencé à être un petit peu
déstabilisé quand même parce que j'ai
l'habitude toujours bien programmé
d'avoir une organisation assez clair
18h30 approche toujours rien
j'aurais tué à l'hôpital
ils ont été déjà était peut-être
beaucoup plus violent pour voir enfin
bref j'ai décidé de continuer à
m'écouter mais c'est vrai que j'étais
quand même assez angoissé de qu'est-ce
qui se passe j'avais toute une
organisation dans la tête j'avais plein
scénario j'avais des repères sur c'était
très raisonnable très cartésien en fait
et là je me retrouvais dans ce no man's
land où j'avais pris sur rien du tout
j'avais je ne pouvais pas contrôler le
temps je pouvais pas contrôler ses
contractions pour accoucher il fallait
juste que je laisse les choses se faire
tout seul
c'est ce message là que j'ai compris à
ce moment là comme si ce petit être en
moins est en train de me dire lâche
prise
arrête de vouloir avoir la maîtrise
surtout arrête d'avoir envie d'avoir le
contrôle sur ce qui se passe et j'ai
fait ce lien entre mon territoire de
féminité et mon espace masculin j'ai
compris qu'en fait l'énergie masculine
ces salles qui met en action
c'est celle qui organise ces salles qui
pose des repères qui donne ce côté
confortable et là j'étais en train
d'explorer un territoire assez inconnu
du lâcher prise
ou vraiment il faut juste laisser les
choses se faire
donc voilà comment j'ai vécu cette
première journée d'attentes qui a été
quand même très très forte pour moi
juste de le traduire par les mots ça
traduit pas complètement vraiment ce que
j'ai vécu
mais j'ai essayé d'écouter cette leçon
et de d'accueillir ce lâcher prise le
lendemain et je peux vous dire que le
1er mai encore un petit clin d'oeil de
l'univers qu'est ce que c'était la
journée du travail
eh ben j'ai appris à ne rien faire ne
rien faire et laisser les choses se
faire par elle même et là j'ai vraiment
eu une grande révélation
être femme accueillir sa partie féminine
accueillir cette énergie féminine qui
nous
guide j'ai compris qu'elle était
vraiment implanté dans ce lâcher prise
dans se laisser faire dans cette écoute
de l'intuition et qu'après ça peut aller
tout seul j'ai eu aussi une autre image
qui m'est venue est une phrase avec
c'est de dire tiens la femme en fin de
compte c'est le berceau de l'humanité et
en même temps c'est également le berceau
de la créativité la plus précise pendant
cet accouchement j'ai dû vraiment aller
en moi même et je suis allé dans un
endroit où je me suis vraiment senti
bien je vais vous le nommez c'est
litteris c'est moi c'est devenu mon
petit chouchou et c'est vraiment un
message que j'ai envie de passer à
toutes les femmes c'est que cet espace
là c'est un espace sacré ce berceau là
c'est vraiment berceau de l'humanité
parce que finalement chacun d'entre nous
chacun d'entre vous vous êtes tous
passés par là avant de fouler cette
terre et en même temps d'avoir écouté
mon intuition d'avoir écouté l'idée qui
était venu à moi de l'avoir sentie
grandir en moi j'ai compris aussi que
l'utérus c'est également un berceau pour
des idées pour la création pour la
créativité
quand on parle de la femme en termes de
chiffres en terme de réussite en terme
de performance moi ce que je ressens
c'est qu'on la mesure c'est qu'on l'ait
value sur des critères de masculinité
c'est à dire à quel point elle a réussi
à faire comme un homme l'homme vers
l'énergie masculine elle est vraiment
basée sur ses repères ce qu'il faut
comprendre
est ce que j'essaye de dire c'est que
autant cette énergie cette énergie
féminine elle est chez la femme elle est
également celle heures on a tous ces
deux énergies en nous mais en tant que
femme on a choisi d'incarner cette
énergie féminine
et donc on a comme un rôle une
responsabilité de la faire réémerger
aujourd'hui sur notre planète
si on prend en compte toute l'histoire
de la féminité
il ya un bout d'histoire qu'on enseigne
pas à l'école
c'est la chasse aux sorcières les
sorcières qui ont été brûlés on dit
souvent pour les gramounes 1-1 dramane
qui part c'est une bibliothèque qui part
en fumée et bien toutes ces femmes qui
ont été brûlés c'est une énorme mémoire
collectif as une énorme bibliothèque qui
a brûlé à ce moment là alors si
aujourd'hui notre société est un petit
peu décalé n'est pas en harmonie
ce que je ressemble c'est parce que on a
oublié ce que c'est que d'être une femme
cette bibliothèque elle a disparu
heureusement on a une mémoire cellulaire
mais elle a été étouffé par des siècles
et des siècles de de formatage je dirais
on a mis la faim dans une situation dans
un imaginaire qui est complètement
différent qui est rabaissée avec toutes
ses valeurs toutes ses qualités
la douceur l'amour dès qu'on parle de ça
on a l'impression dé dans un monde de
bisounours
donc quand on voit une femme aura tout
de suite un homme est un être fragile
par contre il affame empruntent les
critères du masculin et qu'elle monte
lui bah je peux monter une entreprise
peut être chef d'amik à business et là
on se dit ah ouais super qu'elle
battante mais en fait on regarde pas ses
qualités féminines et moissac j'aimerais
qu'on revienne vraiment à la
reconnaissance de toute la valeur des
qualités féminines
pour ça j'ai décidé aussi de vivre une
expérience aujourd'hui
pendant que j'étais pendant la pause
je rigolais mais j'étais là en train de
me dire je suis en train de vie mes
premières contractions
cette conférence tdl je vais la vie
comme un accouchement de qu'il ait vu
depuis que j'ai reçu l'invitation
je me suis juste accroché à mon
intuition à l'idée qui est requis était
venu en moi et j'ai décidé de juste
lâché prise pendant cette conférence de
ne pas préparer de ne pas me faire un
texte sur lequel je pourrai m'appuyer de
juste laisser les choses venir comme
pendant un accouchement ou à chaque
contraction
on doit juste suivre le mouvement et
attendre ce qui vient donc voilà c'est
en mouvement je continue c'est toujours
des petits contraction donc là
j'appellerais ça le trac mais voilà ça
passe c'est beaucoup plus libres
maintenant je respire et je continue
alors dans mon cheminement à travers
cette découverte de la féminité
j'ai vraiment envie de partager ce qui
est venu à moi ce qui m'a vraiment aidé
à me déployés à avoir un nouveau regard
sur tout mon parcours
parce que j'étais très fier enfin je
suis toujours très fier de tout ce que
j'ai fait mais c'est vrai que depuis mon
accouchement j'ai l'impression d'avoir
un autre point de vue sur tout ce que
j'ai fait je les fais dans les foires
j'étais toujours super active on disait
toujours mais esther n'est jamais
fatigué d'une super roo maman mon ego
était très content très flatté je
pouvais faire plein de choses à la fois
mais fin 2014 j'ai quand même eu une
très très grosse fatigue
j'ai pas vu le passage du nouvel an pour
moi c'était y'a rien qui change reste
dans cette course effrénée et je me suis
dit non mais c'est pas possible je peux
pas continuer comme ça et c'est vrai que
je me suis posée en 2015 comme kate pour
l'avenir
apprendre à ne rien faire l'apprécier
sans culpabilité et pendant cet
accouchement j'ai vraiment eu ce message
qui m'a été renvoyé
donc là je sens que cette intuition là
venaient se confirmer donc dans les
outils qui m'ont été transmis dans la
découverte de la féminité et que j'ai
envie de transmettre à toutes les femmes
qui sont là c'est vraiment prendre soin
de soi prend du temps pour aller
explorer qui nous sommes vraiment toutes
ces réalisations toutes ces
concrétisations ne sont qu'une
projection de ce que nous sommes donc au
départ commençons à revenir à la source
parce que nous sommes si on ne sait pas
d'où on vient on ne sait pas où on va
aller donc pour les femmes
je les invite vraiment à retourner
découvrir qu'est ce que leur véritable
féminité quand je parle de féminité ça
veut dire repartir à la con la rencontre
de la jeune fille de la femme amante de
la femme mère de la femme sage de la
sorcière
la jeune fille on peut le guérir toutes
ces blessures qu'elle a eue pendant son
enfance
la femme amante c'est sa relation aux
hommes à la sexualité de travailler sur
tout ça à la fin mr bah la relation de
la femme et de l'enfant moi c'était
domaine dans lequel j'excellais et dans
lequel j'ai vraiment puisé toute mon
énergie
la femme szajda sorcières c'est celle
qui a la sagesse et qui à la connexion
avec la nature avec l'invisible
également tout ça c'est de savoir qui
qui ont existé il ya des siècles et que
j'ai l'impression moi de faire ressurgir
de ma mémoire cellulaire actuellement
c'est au-delà des mots c'est vraiment
des choses qui me reviennent et que je
sens que ça faisait partie de patrimoine
féminin donc en ayant fait ce parcours
de réconciliation avec toutes ces femmes
qui était en moi j'ai compris que je
pouvais être complète et que je pouvais
aussi projeté pour les autres pour mes
filles pour mes soeurs pour mes amis
mais aussi pour mes compagnons ce
référentiel du féminin à partir du
moment où les femmes ont repris
leur pouvoir sur ce que signifie la
féminité sur ce que ça implique
à ce moment là l'homme le masculin peut
prendre ce repère et l'instaurer en lui
à la retrouver l'harmonie c'est ça donc
effectivement on dit souvent
oui mais les hommes les femmes au négoce
ou alors la femme les féministes essaye
de relever les défis du jeu moi je dis
trouvé cette harmonie c'est vraiment
réinvestir ne pouvoir féminin pour
pouvoir le réunionnais et afin que les
hommes en face puis ceux-ci l'installer
en eux et après à partir de là trouver
la bonne combinaison la complémentarité
entre le masculin et le féminin à partir
du moment où moi je me sens ancré dans
mon énergie féminine
je vais utiliser mon énergie masculine
pour mettre en action pour concrétiser
mes idées pour concrétiser mes projets
mon énergie féminine elle me donne
l'intuition comme disait minima tout à
l'heure c'est quelque chose comme une
connexion divin qui me permet vraiment
d'accueillir ce pourquoi je suis là
c'est ma raison d'être
donc chacune chacun on peut comprendre
notre raison d'être sur une autre
planète
sept autres ces autres partis l'énergie
féminine c'est aussi cette qualité d'un
nom cette qualité de douceur à travers
le filtre du coeur je peux vraiment me
dire mon projet vaut la peine et ensuite
je peux partager avec les autres et le
concrétiser grâce aux valeurs masculines
alors très concrètement aujourd'hui ce
que je voudrais inviter chacune à faire
c'est vraiment prenez soin de vous et
allez à la recollection de vous-même
pour retrouver vos parties féminine
votre énergie féminine en créant du
cercle de femmes j'en ai démarré en
premier au 1er février avec des femmes
de mon entourage et je rêve vraiment que
sur l'île il puisse y avoir plein de
cercles de femmes qui se forme et qui
essaime parce que dans ces cercles l'a
d'abord on échange mais on permet de
reconnecter à ses archives féminine qui
nous ont
fait défaut jusqu'à présent et de faire
réémerger tout ça pour que chacune
d'entre nous vivent cette révolution
féminine que j'ai vécu et parce que si
la planète en a besoin parce que la
terre c'est comme une mère universelle
et donc c'est vraiment cette source de
l'énergie féminine à laquelle on et
redit voilà ce que je voulais partager
avec vous tout avec vous tous également
puisque c'est vraiment une
réharmonisation de 10 masculin et du
féminin et c'est ça qui va nous mettre
en mouvement pour retrouver une harmonie
sur la planète
merci